a professional Butler is somebody who is
loyal flexible discreet hardworking
honest but most important it is a person
who has the ability to put somebody
else's wishes before your own that is
what makes this profession so very very
difficult
[Music]
at the age of 21 I became a buffer
nowadays I am chairman of the
International buffer Academy the
International buffer Academy is located
in the beautiful village of simple felt
in the Netherlands we have about a
hundred and thirty five rooms 80,000
square feet completely dedicated to the
training of mothers our students live
here in our building they come literally
from every country in the world age from
eighteen to sixty eight students learn
about housekeeping house management
estate management regular things like
even suitcase packing silver shining
shining shoes the list is enormous there
is an incredible amount of training to
be done in ten weeks
discipline here at the International
Golf Academy is very very important in
order to get a job done you need
discipline I think in order to be
successful you need discipline and
discipline here a school is something we
embrace and not something that we are
afraid of here is cool we always joke
about what employers want they need to
clean toilets they want a warm bed and I
want a hot meal and those three things
are most important for everyone
my wife and I we have our own buffer and
very fortunate I've had a private button
over the past 17 years and this person
was very very important to me being a
buffer can certainly be a wonderful
career simply because if you are
responsible for the well-being of the
family for their happiness that is
obviously very very very important
[Music]